[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande île interview
[Musique]
limitez les rassemblements privé siffler
la fin de la récréation c'est l'appel de
plusieurs médecins et scientifiques
français aujourd'hui 17 décès liés au
virus ces dernières 24 heures et un taux
de positivité qui reste stable
les maisons de retraite ne sont pas
épargnés entre les déclarations
alarmistes et ceux qui relativisent la
dangerosité du virus
la confusion chez les français
un pas vers l'apaisement peut-être en
méditerranée la turquie met un terme à
la mission de son navire d'exploration
maritime dans la zone disputée avec la
grèce mais dans le même temps athènes
annonce la commande de 18 avions rafale
à la france c'est une première pour un
pays européen
hier le président turc a menacé son
homologue français ne cherchez pas
querelle à la turquie at il averti un
accord à tout prix avec les talibans en
afghanistan c'est l'objectif de donald
trump hier des pourparlers entre les
mouvements island le mouvement islamiste
et le gouvernement avant ont débuté au
qatar sous l'égide des états unis les
talibans qui veulent la mise en place
d'un califat une paix à haut risque donc
calé sur l'agenda politique intérieure
du chef de la maison blanche
g
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france dans
cette édition largement consacré à
l'actualité de la semaine et à la une ce
dimanche l'inquiétude de plusieurs
scientifiques français face à la
progression du virus en france
le pays a enregistré 7183 nouveaux cas
ces dernières 24 heures c'est un chiffre
en baisse par rapport à hier
huit décès supplémentaires également
enregistré 8 126 nouveaux foyers de
contamination en cours d'investigation
ses 66 de plus qu'hier
aujourd'hui six médecins et professeurs
français ont signé une tribune dans le
jdd il appelle à siffler la fin de la
récréation il demande aux français
d'être davantage vigilant il suggère
aussi la fin des réunions privées éviter
autant que possible les rassemblements
privé plus une pièce est petite plus
elle contient de monde - elle est aéré
et plus vous augmentez les risques
réduisez le nombre de personnes
présentes dans le cadre privé si
possible reporter toute réunion
et parmi les signataires de cette
tribune bruno mais garbani les chef du
service de réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière et coûteuses et le but
évidemment c'est de responsabiliser et
de mobiliser les citoyens car nous
devons vivre avec le virus et modifier
nos comportements sur une durée
prolongée par la suite évidemment
territoire par territoire il faut une
approche plus ciblée en fonction
évidemment de la situation
épidémiologique cette épidémie a pour
caractéristique de dépendre beaucoup du
département on a des départements où la
situation est 20 fois plus sérieuse que
dans d'autres et donc évidemment on ne
comprendrait pas que des mesures à
l'échelle nationale stricte puisse
convenir à l'ensemble des territoires
d'où le fait bien sûr de responsabiliser
les citoyens et c'est notre rôle est de
donner une mission de santé publique au
maire et aux élus locaux
des élus de la gauche demandant un
moratoire sur la 5g en france dans une
pétition publiée également dans le jdd
plusieurs politiques de la gauche
radicale et écologiste demande la tenue
d'un débat démocratique
il regrette l'absence d'étude d'impact
climatique et environnementale avant le
déploiement de cette nouvelle
technologie
le gouvernement lui justifie une mise en
place rapide de ce réseau par un manque
de compétitivité
voyez ce qu'on dit michel larive député
la france insoumise de la 2e
circonscription de l'ariège signate
signataires de cette tribune et la
problématique est la suivante c'est de
cette potion potentialités n'a pas été
étudiée aucun rapport gouvernemental
nous disent elles peuvent cette
dangerosité potentielle médias plus
georges auto problème un problème
d'abord écologique
cette une technologie à haute fréquence
donc il faut multiplier les antennes
ensuite on utilise d'autres matériels il
faudra donc construire d'autres
matériels on aura donc un besoins
énergétiques énormes
par exemple en chine la nuit on éteint
ses antennes ensuite la menace de
données personnelles l'interconnexion
c'est que les états pourront avoir accès
à nos données personnelles via d'autres
applications
les états mais aussi de grandes
multinationales comme les guerres fans
et puis la dépendance technologique
étrangères c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la france et l'europe en général n'a pas
bouclé son protocole 5 g donc nous
serons dépendants d'une technologie
étrangère notamment peut-être de huawei
qui est numéro un mondial là dessus mais
aussi des américains qui veulent
absolument très sexy danto choisissent
une technologie occidentale
après la manifestation des gilet jaune
hier à paris plusieurs journalistes
indépendants affirme via les réseaux
sociaux avoir été arrêtés alors qu'ils
couvraient les manifestations d'hier
elle l'un d'entre eux julien moreau dit
avoir été placé en garde à vue pendant
plus de dix heures pour je cite
participation à un groupement en vue de
préparer des violences contre des
personnes ou des destructions
écoutez justement le témoignage de
julien moreau ce journaliste indépendant
qui vient de sortir de garde à vue
notifier mon interpellation pour le
motif de vérification d'identité est
donc suite à ça j'ai attendu une bonne
vingtaine de minutes un véhicule est
venu me récupérer en un mot n'est au
commissariat du xviiie arrondissement
ah bah ouais donc de là je suis passé
devant au pgi qui m'a simplement notifié
que j'étais une mise en garde à vue
parce que j'étais plus équipés que les
forces de l'ordre que leurs collègues
c'était un gilet tactique semblable à
celui des forces de l'ordre avec un gros
logo presse déjà quand je suis arrivé
dans la cellule il y avait déjà un
journaliste citoyen donc c'est pour un
média méditant par compte et il était
venu simplement avec du matériel vidéo
et un simple masque à gaz et il a été
interpellé pour juste pour le masquer la
ja j'ai eu le retour après ma sortie de
garde à vue qu'il ya eu deux ou trois
autres journalistes qui ont été à
l'avant garde à vue pour les mêmes
raisons que le colonel ces
manifestations de soutien aux
journalistes emprisonnés en algérie
place de la bastille et place de la
république aujourd'hui à paris la
communauté algérienne qui appelle à la
libération immédiate du journaliste
khaled draps dresny en raison de son
état de santé
il a été condamné à trois ans de prison
ferme pour atteinte à l'intégrité
territoriale
après avoir couvert une manifestation
populaire contre le pouvoir c'était le 7
mars dernier
les protestataires demandent le respect
de toutes les libertés en algérie
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter nadège abderrazak la
manifestation est partie en début
d'après midi de la place de la
république pour atteindre en fin de
journée
place de la bastille et quelques
milliers de personnes ont participé à ce
rassemblement pour demander la
libération immédiate de khaled adrar ni
ceux journalistes de tv5-monde
correspondant de reporters sans
frontières avait été arrêté à la fin du
mois de mars après avoir couvert une
manifestation du irak ce mouvement de
contestation inédit qui a secoué
l'algérie pendant plus d'un angle son
procès en appel
et dans deux jours en première instance
il a été condamné à une peine de trois
ans de prison pour incitation
attroupement et atteinte à l'unité
nationale ses proches dénoncent une
incarcération arbitraire injuste je vous
propose de les écouter le message est
clair c'est un message d'union c'est un
message d'espoir c'est un message de
lutte démocratique qui naquit ne
s'arrête pas c'est des femmes des hommes
des vieux des gamins qui viennent
aujourd'hui affirmer notre volonté
commune d'aller vers un état
démocratique vers une démocratie majeure
nous sommes là ici pour dénoncer les
arrestations arbitraires les détenus
politiques les journalistes injustement
emprisonnées nous sommes là algérienne
algériens toutes tendances confondues
qui croyant à la démocratie qui croyant
à cette flûte de tout un peuple depuis
l'indépendance c'est le grand message
aujourd'hui à la place de la république
fait on est là à la place de la
république pour dire au peuple algérien
qui souffre à l'intérieur du pays qu'on
est là pour le sud pour le soutenir pour
être à ses côtés pour dire aussi au
pouvoir algérien qu'il est temps qu'il
parte
nous voulons un changement radical un
changement pacifique
nous voulons une transition démocratique
indépendante du pouvoir de 600 vols
depuis 1962 à ce jour la situation est
restée telle qu'il y avait pas le
citoyen a toujours vécu dans la
soumission et face à un pouvoir
totalitaire qui domine ce peuple dans
tous les domaines et depuis
l'arrestation de khaled rare ni en
algérie plusieurs autres journalistes
ont été incarcérés ils sont accusés par
les autorités de menacer l intérêt
national et d'être à la solde de deux
parties étrangères au classement mondial
de la liberté de la presse établi par
reporters sans frontières
l algérie pointe désormais à la 146e
place sur 180 et perd donc 27 places par
rapport à 2015 un pas vers l'apaisement
peut-être en méditerranée la turquie met
un terme à la mission de son navire
d'exploration maritime dans la zone
disputée avec la grèce mais dans le même
temps athènes a annoncé aujourd'hui la
commande de 18 avions rafale à la france
dont douze au d'occasions mais c'est
quand même une première pour un pays
européen
hier le président turc a menacé son
homologue français ne cherchez pas
querelle à la turquie at il averti
cyrielle boe et david khalifa rien ne va
plus entre paris et ankara
alors que la situation en méditerranée
orientale s'enflamme recep tayyip
erdogan tape du poing sur la table dans
un discours télévisé le président turc
s'en prend directement à emmanuel macron
scène vous ne connaissez même pas
l'histoire de la france
d'abord ne cherchez pas que ray le
peuple turc ne cherchait pas querelle à
la turquie mais dans son discours le
président turc fait référence aux
critiques émises par le président
français envers ankara
ce jeudi en corse emmanuel macron a
pointé du doigt la turquie lors de
l'ouverture du sommet m 7
ce forum informel composé de sept pays
du sud de l'europe aux racines latines
lancée en 2016 sur fond de crise
économique grecque pour répondre aux
défis économiques et migratoires mais
nous devons nous européens être clair et
ferme avec non pas la turquie comme
nation comme peuple mais avec le
gouvernement du président erdogan qui
aujourd'hui à des comportements
inadmissibles les gens ne citer qu'une
partie depuis plusieurs semaines la
question de la recherche et de la
propriété des gisements d'hydrocarbures
provoque une véritable escalade de
saillies verbales et de démonstration de
force entre la grèce et chypre d'un côté
et la turquie de l'autre athènes et
nicosie dénonce les prospections turque
dans les eaux que les deux capitales
estiment relever de leur souveraineté
des mouvements semblent aller vers
l'apaisement
ce dimanche la turquie confirme que son
navire de recherche en méditerranée à
regagner la côte
soulagement du côté grec le retour de
leur graisse à antalya est un premier
pas positif
j'espère sincèrement que cela va se
poursuivre j'ai dit que la fin des
provocations devait être le début de la
conversation
nous n'avons jamais caché le fait que
nous voulons parler avec la turquie mais
dans une atmosphère pacifique sans
provocation ce que les 100 actions
unilatérales juge crowley skieuse mort
mais les chaînes à neige un dossier
majeur pour emmanuel macron
particulièrement impliqué depuis le
début dans cette crise
le président français a affirmé au cours
des dernières semaines son soutien à ses
homologue chypriote et grecque et
déployant même plusieurs bâtiments de
guerre dans la zone concernée
une initiative vivement critiquée par le
président turc
la turquie sera au coeur du prochain
sommet européen prévu les 24 et 25
septembre
et voyez à présent l'analyse de françois
chauvancy général et expert en
géopolitique le pensent ou sentent en
une certaine manipulation de turc pour
laisser croire que elle va être plus
calme dans ses approches mais
personnellement je ne crois pas compte
tenu de ce qui se passe depuis des mois
sinon des années que la turquie veille
de calmer le jeu
pour l'instant nous sommes dans des
rapports de force qui ne sont pas
militaire proprement dit mais des
rapports de force de façade
donc il faut savoir un petit peu ce qui
va se passer par la suite avec art hogan
mais ce qu'il a dit vis-à-vis du
président macron contre à l'évidence qui
n'a pas l'intention de céder sur un
certain nombre de points 18 avions
rafale ce n'est pas négligeable
c'est un achat rapide il faut bien sûr
former des pilotes mais cela montre que
face à la turquie personne n'a
l'intention au moins dans cette zone de
baisser les bras
la grèce toujours confrontée à une grave
crise migratoire athènes qui annonce
l'ouverture d'un nouveau camp d'ici à
cinq jours près de 12 millions sont
toujours sans abri depuis l' incendie
mercredi pas du conte de moria sur l'île
de lesbos des migrants qui refuse d'être
hébergés dans le nouveau centre depuis
hier ils manifestent pour réclamer leur
transfèrent ailleurs l'union européenne
a promis d'en accueillir à l'instar de
la france qui n'a pas précisé combien la
grèce assure que toutes les demandes
d'asile seront examinés tous les
réfugiés tous les demandeurs d'asile qui
se trouve actuellement sur l'île seront
déplacés ici temporairement et les
services d'asile continuerons à examiner
leur cas conformément au droit
international et européen et ceux qui
n'ont pas droit à la protection
internationale seront rapatriés dans
leur pays d'origine comme cela est
également prévue notre priorité dans les
prochains jours est de faire en sorte
que tout le monde soit en sécurité et
disposent de tout ce dont il a besoin
d'un point de vue humanitaire
nouvelle passe d'armes sur le bras exit
l'irlande dénonce les mensonges de boris
johnson la ministre irlandaise de la
justice a réfuté aujourd'hui les
allégations du premier ministre
britannique
boris johnson a affirmé hier dans la
presse que l'union européenne menace y
est d'instaurer je cite un blocus
alimentaire en irlande du nord
les accusations de blocus qui ont
provoqué la colère des pays membres
regardez toute insinuation selon
laquelle cela va créer une nouvelle
frontière est tout simplement fausse
le traité garantit également l'intégrité
de l'irlande du nord en tant que partie
intégrante du royaume uni le royaume uni
est une grande démocratie il est
inconcevable que le gouvernement et le
parlement reviennent sur un texte qu'ils
ont eux mêmes négocier et voter rognant
la parole donnée ces manifestations du
personnel de santé en belgique pour un
meilleur financement des soins et une
augmentation des salaires vous le voyez
est la belgique est l'un des pays
européens les plus endeuillé par la
pandémie du coc vide avec près de dix
mille morts à ce stade
et puis sachez que face à la progression
de l'épidémie
israël a annoncé un recond finement
nationale de trois semaines nouvelle
manifestation de l'opposition en
biélorussie des dizaines de milliers de
personnes réunies ce dimanche à minsk
contre la réélection du président
alexandre loukachenko
400 personnes ont été arrêtées au motif
d'avoir utilisé des drapeaux et autres
symboles de l'opposition ainsi que des
pancartes et des messages jugés
offensants
le président loukachenko qui a réuni lui
plusieurs hauts responsables des agences
de sécurité à la veille d'une rencontre
avec le président russe vladimir poutine
il a dénoncé notamment les exercices en
cours de l'otan dans les pays voisins
prémices selon lui à son renversement
la biélorussie qui a récemment renforcé
sa présence militaire à l'ouest
si les troupes de l'otan en pologne en
lituanie ont terminé les soi-disant
exercices militaires et ne s'y déplacent
plus nous devons réagir de manière
adéquate
après dire monsieur chat
nous ne pouvons pas y maintenir les
forces armées pendant longtemps sans
nécessité cela coûte cher
s'il ya toujours les mêmes événements
qu'il y à un mois j'écoute vos
suggestions
c'est jour de vote en russie trois jours
même les électeurs de quarante et une
région sont appelés à élire leur
gouverneur et leurs assemblées locales
ainsi que quatre députés de la douma
un scrutin qui intervient en pleine
affaire alexeï navalni les partisans de
l'opposante ont appelé je cite à un vote
intelligent c'est la stratégie
habituelle de l'opposition pour tenter
de faire chuter les candidats du pouvoir
dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
coronavirus les autorités locales ont
autorisé donc un scrutin sur trois jours
exceptionnellement avec des bureaux de
vote en plein air voyez les enjeux de
cette élection avec notre correspondant
à moscou
antoine gayraud les enjeux de ce scrutin
sont multiples concrètement il s'agit de
renouveler 18 gouverneurs de régions une
dizaine de parlements régionaux ou
encore quatre députés à la douma pour de
nombreux observateurs il s'agit aussi
d'une répétition générale avant les
élections législatives de 2021
l'occasion donc de mesurer la popularité
ou le désamour c'est selon du parti
présidentiel russie unie à ce titre delà
des résultats qui ne devrait pas
réserver trop de grande surprise il
faudra regarder le taux de participation
il sera aussi intéressant d'observer
l'impact éventuel qu'a eue la sphère
navalni sur les électeurs par exemple
dans la région de novossibirsk troisième
ville de russie où l'opposition est plus
structuré qu'ailleurs et acquis
l'opposant russe avait affiché son
soutien à noter également que dans
plusieurs bureaux de vote d
gallery t ont été signalés dont
certaines font déjà l'objet d'une
enquête
plusieurs niveaux de lecture donc pour
des résultats officiels qui ne seront
pas connus par tous avant plusieurs
jours
la serbie ne participera pas aux
exercices militaires conjoints avec la
russie qui c'est qui devait se dérouler
en biélorussie initialement c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le ministre serbe de la
défense voyez pourquoi en images la
serbie devait participer ce mois ci aux
exercices militaires fraternité clave
2020 mais le ministre serbe de la
défense
aleksandar vu line a annoncé renoncer à
y participer
on nous a demandé au prix d'un abandon
de notre avenir européen de renoncer aux
exercices militaires prévus avec la
biélorussie la serbie qui est neutre sur
le plan militaire a été confrontée à une
forte pression non méritée de la part de
l'union européenne et suspendra en
conséquence sa participation aux
exercices militaires avec tous ses
partenaires pendant six mois une
décision qui n'affectera pas la relation
qui lie la serbie à la russie comme l'a
expliqué le porte parole du kremlin
on ne peut que constater le fait que la
serbie a suspendu tous les exercices
militaires pour les six prochains mois
ce n'est pas à cause de la russie ou
d'un autre pays nous respectons cette
décision des autorités serbes
en août dernier la serbie a été
complimenté par des ambassadeurs
occidentaux après avoir apporté son
soutien à une déclaration de l'union
européenne critiquant l'élection
présidentielle controversée en
biélorussie depuis le 2 mars 2012 la
serbie est reconnu comme candidat
officiel pour l'union européenne
le pays a entamé les négociations en
janvier
1014 en 2018 la commission européenne a
indiqué que l'adhésion de la serbie ne
se ferait pas avant 2025
sept pays sont actuellement candidat
pour entrer dans l'union européenne
l'albanie la macédoine du nord le
monténégro le kosovo la turquie la
bosnie herzégovine et la serbie
un accord de paix à tout prix avec les
talibans en afghanistan c'est l'objectif
de donald trump
hier des pourparlers entre le mouvement
islamiste et le gouvernement afghan ont
débuté au qatar sous l'égide des états
unis les talibans qui veulent la mise en
place d'un califat une paix à haut
risque donc calé sur l'agenda politique
intérieure du chef de la maison blanche
françois tisc et vite c'est dans un
hôtel de luxe de doha que les
pourparlers ont commencé c'est celui là
même qui avait accueilli en février
dernier la signature de l'accord
historique entre washington et les
talibans
entérinant le retrait militaire
américain nous sommes venus pour
parvenir à une paix digne et durable
nous sommes venus ici avec bonne volonté
bonnes intentions afin d'arrêter des 40
ans d'effusion de sang et parvenir à une
paix durable dans tout le pays
pis le processus de négociation peut
avoir des problèmes
mais les pourparlers doivent aller de
l'avant avec beaucoup de patience avec
beaucoup d'attention et de réflexion et
ils devraient être poursuivis avec ce
genre d'attention des négociations
retardée de six mois en raison de
désaccord profond sur un échange de
prisonniers et les premières discussions
se sont bien déroulées selon l'émissaire
américain pour la paix en afghanistan
je pense que les choses se déroule
relativement bien et nous sommes
certainement prudent les délégations
afghane se sont rencontrées elles ont
nommé un comité de chaque côté et elles
se réuniront à nouveau pour élaborer une
feuille de route pour leur travail
les talibans ne reconnaissent pas le
gouvernement de kaboul qu'ils qualifient
de marionnette de washington et veulent
un pays régi par un système islamique où
la loi sur édictées par un islam
rigoriste le gouvernement afghan lui
insiste pour maintenir la jeune
république et sa constitution qui a
consacré de nombreux droits notamment
pour les femmes
grande perdante d'un retour possible aux
pratiques en vigueur sous le joug des
talibans
beaucoup d'afghans cren d'ailleurs leur
retour au pouvoir partielle ou totale
toute guerre se termine par la paix il
ne fait aucun doute que la guerre en
afghanistan se terminera aussi par la
paix bien que je ne sois pas optimistes
quant à la fin de la paix en afghanistan
je ne crois pas que les talibans
obtiendront le pouvoir car c'était une
condition imposée par le gouvernement
afghan et la communauté internationale
dès le départ il pourrait faire partie
du gouvernement en ayant quelques
ministères ou ambassades
ils ne peuvent pas être un parti
décisionnel dans son ensemble des
négociations qui s'annoncent longues et
ardues
afin de mettre un terme à près de 20 ans
de conflit qui ont tué des dizaines de
milliers de personnes et poussé des
millions d'autres à fuir au mali le
mouvement de contestation rejettent la
proposition de transition de la junte au
pouvoir l'opposition qui dénonce je cite
une volonté d'accaparement et de
confiscation du pouvoir au profit du
conseil national de salut du peuple qui
a été instituée par les putschistes
un texte qui prévoit une période de 18
mois avant de transmettre le pouvoir aux
civils mais avec un président désigné
par l'armée
écoutez le colonel assimi koanda c'est
l'actuel homme fort du pays
la mazda 2 va vous de ne ménager aucun
effort dans la mise à
l'ensemble de ces résolutions dans
l'intérêt exclusif du peuple malien nous
défendons et espère la compréhension
l'appui et l'accompagnement de la
communauté internationale d'un service
en les dirigeant aurait qu ils achètent
et de la fédé route de la transition
les résultats auxquels vous êtes
parvenus motors resterait l'événement
des manuels nouveau démocratique
leape préfère fond de tout le travail
reste ici sociale et l'égalité
la côte d'ivoire elle a ouvert les
investitures pour la présidentielle du
31 octobre prochain
l'ancien premier ministre ivoirien
guillaume soro a été investi par
contumace il est toujours en exil en
france
l'ancien président henri konan bédié lui
a été officiellement désigné par son
parti hier le parti démocrate de la côte
d'ivoire l'opposition dénonce la
candidature un troisième mandat de
l'actuel chef de l'état alassane
ouattara
plusieurs recours ont été déposés devant
le conseil constitutionnel
voyez ce qu'on dit le sociologue
rodrigues connaît l'opposition essaie de
se mobiliser pour pouvoir contrecarrer
cette candidature d'alassane ouattara
mais qui semble être un acteur bien
positionné dans le contexte
comparativement au présent et bk qui
avait cette forte contestation de plus
longtemps et ici c'est une partie de la
population qui contexte sa candidature
et il a ses partisans et donc nous
sommes dans un jeu de rapports de force
entre une opposition qui est en train de
se structurer de renforcer son
positionnement à mobiliser la rue est un
parti au pouvoir qui tient la machine
d'appareils d'état l'histoire nous
enseigne que à chaque fois le conseil
constitutionnel et ses rangs des
décisions qui sont plus proches du
pouvoir que de l'opposition que celle de
l'opposition
donc le sang peut être présager de ce
qui sera dit il est fort probable que le
conseil constitutionnel puisse valider
la candidature de monsieur alassane
ouattara et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes reste
elle
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dont des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui jugé amadou gon
coulibaly est possédée pourquoi
aujourd'hui
le président et candidat à sa propre
succession nous estimons que les plus en
retard à est celui qui a le leadership
nécessaire pour faire face au public se
pose à nous d'en haut niveau